the remarkable story of service and
sacrifice and long overdue recognition
for a world war ii veteran crescencia
garcia is 102 years old i'm going to say
that again she's 102
years old people one of the last
surviving members of an all-female
all-black unit that served in england
during the war it's the only military
women's unit to receive the
congressional gold medal and garcia's
role in its very vital mission is
finally coming to light why because
she's got a very loving granddaughter
she introduced chris cincia garcia to
our lead national correspondent david
bagnow and so you know magic's got to
happen this morning david takes us on a
journey through her long life with a
special surprise tribute you will not
want to miss it's kind of crazy
two years ago i received a message from
tara garcia hi david she told me that
her grandmother chrysencia had beaten
covid at the age of 100. now that was at
the beginning of the pandemic and we all
needed good news then so i tweeted about
it and included pictures that tara had
sent to me one of which included her
grandmother in a military uniform i just
knew that she was a veteran and that she
was in the army and she was very proud
that tweet went viral and it was seen by
retired army colonel edna cummings it
was like
being in a casino and hitting the
jackpot she started connecting some dots
and reached out to garcia's family
she spoke to tara she says
let's start here give me her dog tag
numbers and we'll compare them as it
turns out she was in a burn unit about
30 kilometers from birmingham england
treating soldiers because it was such a
manpower shortage all over you know
europe
[Music]
get this chrysencia garcia is one of
only six surviving members of an
all-female all-black segregated unit
that was sent overseas during world war
ii known as the six triple eight the 855
women that served in that unit are now
receiving long overdue recognition
they're the only military women's unit
to receive the congressional gold medal
they are part of an elite group of less
than 200 recipients the first being
general george washington and i was just
like you've got to be kidding me and
everything matched up and i looked at my
parents and it's like i think we just
opened pandora's box here they sure did
they found out that ms garcia's name is
on a monument at fort leavenworth in
kansas now as the family's finding out
about all this i had no clue i never
heard from tara again
i got a call from the good folks at
oprah daily in fact i was here at home
and they said david we were just pitched
about a story involving a 102 year old
woman who served during world war ii and
her family is only now learning stories
that they've never heard before so my
team said we got to do something so they
called tara
and we had a surprise
may i say hello
oh dude how are you
i have wanted to meet you
are you kidding me
surprise
oh the pleasure is
well i came to listen
hi hi oh my gosh okay i'm so sorry
it's okay i i feel the same miss
crescencio my name is david davey david
hi davey hi it's very nice to meet you
it's an honor actually
to meet you it is
it is for you
she enlisted in the us army at the age
of 24 after being enraged by the bombing
of pearl harbor
the army sent her to texas for basic
training they put me in the black
section
and there is the white section
that's america to you
see
that's america to you
and it's very sad
you know
very sad i want to talk about
your service
lesson was it wasn't much no i was just
a medic
you were a medic yeah i was just to take
care of the hurt the hurt when they came
in i took care of them
thank you for your service
welcome
i am proud to be an american what is
this moment like for you
i am delighted that everyone gets to see
what i see because some people don't
they don't get it until you actually
experience it and see it you don't live
to be 102 without being a spark i mean
right you're full of life
you are
oh my gosh
you just reminded her oh careful could
you be my grandson oh
you look great you look great thank you
mrs garcia was born in puerto rico on
april 18 1920.
a loaf of bread cost you 12 cents then
woodrow wilson was the president and
women didn't have the right to vote when
world war ii began she told us she had
already moved to new york city and felt
a patriotic duty to serve her country
after the war she married esteban garcia
ii an army veteran himself they raised
three children in the bronx
she spent her post-war work years
working as a seamstress and a pattern
maker in new york city's garment
district
her husband died in 1994 after 47 years
of marriage that's my grandfather let me
see this handsome man now we had
arranged for a little surprise from mrs
garcia but the surprise timeline was a
little off and she was getting a little
restless so
what were we gonna do you want scott
i have daddy walker danny will you want
you want one yeah yeah
she wants us
does she really can we cheers
a toast
a toast to you to me at 102. thank you
to you and 102.
finally the phone rang
so i have
one other surprise for you
can you answer that please
[Music]
hello tara
hi how are you it's jill biden how are
you doing
hi
i'm great how are you i'm great too
i hear you have a very special
grandmother i do i do hello hi it's jill
biden
oh
uh-huh
wow my salute for you woman
you're the one that needs to be
celebrated you are one incredible woman
and i can't thank you enough for all
your service to our country and i salute
you
keep it up keep up the good work
i'm trying to follow in your footsteps
and in your example thank you thank you
tara for sharing this moment with me and
with all of america thank you so much
really nice to meet you take care love
you mrs garcia's memory is fading but
let me tell you in that moment
she was fully present how amazing was
that
the fact that she
knew who that was yeah
and she felt
that that acknowledgement just now
that's all i needed that's all i needed
i said i just want her to remember
that's all
oh
wow you were trying to guess who the
surprise was because i said uh oprah
yeah maybe tyler perry no that's even
better to have the first lady of the
united states say i salute you that was
so fantastic and her response to the
first lady is what caught us all of god
i salute you yes yes yes and she clearly
knew that it was dr joe biden too
absolutely let me tell you a little bit
more about that unit she served in the
six triple eight a lot of them were sent
overseas to sort the mail because the
mail wasn't arriving to the servicemen
and the morale was really low
but of the women who went according to
the historian we talked to edna cummings
some of them were light enough to pass
for white and so they were able to do
other duties and miss garcia was one of
them that's how she wound up as a medic
you had so many layers to that story
david from the very beginning ending
with jill biden so did you just call the
white house and say hey do you think the
first lady would do this because that
takes a lot to get that
that's
what we did and they were very gracious
we shot this story almost a month ago
but the first lady was was very gracious
and guess what guys today just so
happens to be
the 75th anniversary of when mrs garcia
married her husband
wow
well you know what's awesome it looks
great too it's remarkable that that
generation they don't talk about to them
she said it was just a job i was a medic
and even her granddaughter wasn't known
fully aware of the details because they
did this heroic job and they came home
and raised families and got married and
fulfilled the american dream they never
talked about it but now they're being
honored for it david beautiful wonderful
story david thank you appreciate it
bravo bravo